Hi, I’m John Green. This is Crash Course
World History. And apparently it’s Revolutions
Month here at Crash Course, because today
we are going to discuss the often-neglected
Haitian Revolutions. The Haitian Revolutions
are totally fascinating and they involve two
of my very favorite things:
1. Ending slavery, and
2. Napoleon getting his feelings hurt. I can’t
help myself, Napoleon. I like to see you suffer.
[theme music]
So, the French colony in Saint-Domingue began
in the 17th century as a pirate outpost. And
its original French inhabitants made their
living selling leather and a kind of smoked
beef called boucan. All that beef actually
came from cattle left behind by the Spanish,
who were the first Europeans to settle the
island.
But anyway, after 1640, the boucan-sellers
started to run low on beef. And they were
like, “You know what would pay better than
selling beef jerky? Robbing Spanish galleons,”
which as you’ll recall were loaded with
silver mined from South America. So, by the
middle of the 17th century, the French had
convinced many of those buccaneering captains
to give up their pirating and settle on the
island.
Many of them invested some of their pirate
treasure in sugar plantations, which, by 1700
were thriving at both producing sugar and
working people to death. And soon, this island
was the most valuable colony in the West Indies,
and possibly in the world. It produced 40%
of Europe’s sugar, 60% of its coffee, and it was
home to more slaves than any place except Brazil.
And as you’ll recall from our discussion
of Atlantic slavery, being a slave in a sugar-production
colony was exceptionally brutal. In fact,
by the late 18th century, more slaves were
imported to Saint-Domingue EVERY YEAR— more
than 40,000— than the entire white population
of the island. By the 19th century, slaves
made up about 90% of the population.
And most of those slaves were African born,
because the brutal living and working conditions
prevented natural population growth. Like,
remember Alfred Crosby’s fantastic line,
“it is crudely true that if man’s caloric
intake is sufficient, he will somehow stagger
to maturity, and he will reproduce?” Yeah,
well, not in 18th century Haiti, thanks to
Yellow Fever and smallpox and just miserable
working conditions. So, most of these plantations
were pretty large, they often had more than
200 slaves, and many of the field workers—
in some cases, a majority— were women.
Colonial society in Saint-Domingue was divided
into four groups, which had important consequences
for the revolution. At the top, were the Big
White planters who owned the plantations and
all the slaves. Often these Grand Blancs were
absentee landlords who would just rather stay
in France and let their agents do, you know,
the actual brutality.
Below them were the wealthy free people of
color. Most of the Frenchmen who came to the
island were, you know, men, and they frequently
fathered children with slave women. These
fathers would often free their children. Wasn’t
that generous of them. So, by 1789, there
were 24,800 free people of color along with
about 30,000 white people in the colony. The
free people of color contributed a lot to
the island’s stability. They served in the
militia, and in the local constabulary, and
many of the wealthier ones eventually owned
plantations and slaves of their own.
And then, below them on the social ladder were
the poor whites, or the petit blancs, who worked
as artisans and laborers. And at the bottom were
the slaves who made up the overwhelming majority.
I know what you’re thinking: this is a recipe
for permanent social stability. No, it wasn’t.
Okay, so when the French Revolution broke
out in 1789, all these groups had something
to complain about. The slaves, obviously,
disliked being slaves. The free people of
color were still subject to legal discrimination,
no matter how wealthy they became.
And the poor whites, in addition to being
poor, were resentful of all the privileges
held by the wealthy people of color. And the
Grand Blancs were complaining about French
trade laws and the government’s attempts
to slightly improve the living and working
conditions of slaves. Basically they were
saying that government shouldn’t be in the
business of regulating business. So everyone
was unhappy, but the slaves were by far the worst off.
Mr. Green, Mr. Green! You’re always saying
how much slavery sucks, but is it really any
worse than having to work for, like, subsis...
Yeah, I’m gonna stop you right there, Me
from the Past, before you further embarrass
yourself. You often hear from people attempting
to comprehend the horrors of slavery that
slavery couldn’t have been all that bad,
and that it wasn’t that different from working
for minimum wage. And that we know this because
if it HAD been so bad, slaves would have just
revolted, which they never did. Yeah. Well,
1. equating slavery to poor working conditions
ignores the fact that if you work at, like,
Foxconn, Foxconn doesn’t get to sell your
children to other corporations. And
2. As you are about to see, SLAVES DID REVOLT.
So, the unrest in what became Haiti started
in 1789 when some slaves heard a rumor that
the King of France had freed them. Even though
it was across the ocean, word of the changes
in France reached the people of Haiti, where
The Declaration of Rights of Man and Citizen,
while terrifying to planters, gave hope both
to free people of color and to slaves.
At the same time, some petit blancs argued
that there was inadequate discrimination against
blacks. They identified with the third estate
in France, and they called for interest rates
to be lowered so they could more easily pay their debts.
And they began lobbying for colonial independence.
The psychology here shows you the extent to
which slaves were not considered people. I
mean, these radical petit blancs thought that
they were the oppressed people in Saint-Domingue
because they couldn’t afford to own slaves.
And they thought if they could become independent
from France, they could take power from the
people of privilege and institute a democracy
where everyone had a voice-- except for the
95% of people who weren’t white.
Then in 1791, these radical petit blancs seized
the city of Port-au-Prince. You’ll remember
that by 1791, France was at war with most
of Europe, and just like with the 7 Years’
War, the wars of Revolutionary France played
out in the colonies as well as at home. So
the French government sent troops to Saint-Domingue.
Meanwhile, urges toward liberty, fraternity,
and equality were only growing in France,
and it didn’t seem very equitable to grant
citizenship based solely on race. So in May
of 1791, the National Assembly gave full French
citizenship to all free men of color. I mean,
if they owned property, and had enough money,
and weren’t the children of slaves. The
petit blancs weren’t thrilled about this,
and that led to fighting breaking out between
them and the newly French free people of color.
And then in August of 1791, the slaves were
like, “Um, hi, yes. Screw all of you.”
And a massive slave revolt broke out. Among
the leaders of this revolt was Toussaint Breda,
a former slave of full African descent, who later
took the name Toussaint L’ouverture. L’Ouverture
helped mold the slaves into a disciplined army
that could withstand attacks from the French troops.
But again, the context of the wider revolution
proves really important here. So, the Spanish
had consistently supported slave revolts in
Saint-Domingue hoping to weaken the French.
But, by 1793 they were offering even more
support. In fact, L’Ouverture became an
officer in the Spanish military because the
emancipation of the slaves was more important
to him than maintaining his rights as a French
Citizen.
So then, in October of 1793 the British, whom
as I’m sure you’ll recall were also at
war with France, decided to invade Saint-Domingue.
And at that point, the French military commanders
were like, We are definitely going to lose
this war if we fight the British, the Spanish,
and the slaves, so let’s free the slaves.
So they issued decrees freeing the slaves
and on February 4, 1794 the National Convention
in Paris ratified those decrees.
By May, having learned of the Convention’s
actions, L’Ouverture switched allegiances
to the French and turned the tide of the war.
Thus, the most successful slave revolt in
human history won freedom and citizenship
for every slave in the French Caribbean. But
emancipation didn’t end the story because
the French were still at war with the Spanish
and the English in Saint-Domingue. Luckily
for France, L’Ouverture was an excellent
general, and luckily for the people of the
island, L’Ouverture was also an able politician.
And between 1794 and 1802, he successfully
steered the colony toward independence.
So, although slavery was abolished, this didn’t
end the plantation system because both L’Ouverture
and his compatriot André Rigaud believed
that sugar was vital to the economic health
of the island. But now at least people were
paid for their labor and their kids couldn’t
be sold. Now you can compare it to Foxconn.
But soon, L’Ouverture and Rigaud came into
conflict over Rigaud’s refusal to give up
control over one of the Southern states on
the island, and there was a civil war, which
L’Ouverture, with the help of his able lieutenant
Jacques Dessalines, was able to win after
13 months of hard fighting. L’Ouverture
then passed a new constitution, and things
were going pretty well on Saint-Domingue with
the small problem that it was still technically part of
France, which meant that it was about to be ruled by
Napoleon Bonaparte. Let’s go to the Thought Bubble.
So, in 1799, Napoleon seized power in France
in a coup. And, his new regime, called the
Consulate (because he was the First Consul
à la the Roman Republic) established a new
constitution that specifically pointed out its
laws did not apply to France’s overseas colonies.
Napoleon had plans to reconstruct France’s
empire in North America that it had lost most
of in the 7 Years’ War, and to do this he
needed tons of money from France’s most
valuable colony, Saint-Domingue. And the best
way to maximize profits? Why, to reintroduce
slavery, of course. That’s certainly what
the former slaves thought was the plan when
in 1802, a French expedition commanded by
Napoleon’s brother in-law Charles-Victor-Emmanuel
“I-Have-Too-Many-Names” Leclerc showed
up in Saint-Domingue.
This started the second phase of the Haitian
revolution, the fight for independence. So,
Leclerc eventually had L’Ouverture arrested
and shipped to France where he died in prison
in 1803. But this itself did not spark an
uprising against the French because L’Ouverture
wasn’t actually that popular, largely because he wanted
most blacks on the island to continue to grow sugar.
Instead, the former slaves only started fighting
when Leclerc tried to take away their guns,
thus beginning a guerrilla war that the French,
despite their superior training and weapons,
had absolutely no chance of winning. Although
the French were exceedingly cruel, executing
women as well as men and importing man-eating
dogs from Cuba, the Haitians had the best
ally of all: Disease, specifically in the
form of Yellow Fever, which killed thousands
of French soldiers, including Leclerc himself.
Oh, it’s time for the Open Letter?
Stan! Where is my chair? Stan, you’re telling
me the yellow chair has been lost? The yellow
chair is the star of the show. The stars,
in order, are 1. me, 2. yellow chair, 3. the
chalkboard, 4. Danica, 5. Meredith the Intern,
6. you, Stan. You’re sixth. Oh, I’m mad.
Let’s see what’s in the secret compartment
today. It’s a giant squid of anger!!! I’M
A GIANT SQUID OF ANGER!!!! Oh, no. It broke.
An open letter to disease. Dear disease, why do you
always put yourself at the center of human history?
Most of you are just tiny, little single-celled
organisms, but you’re so self-important
and self-involved that you’re always interfering
with us. Admittedly, sometimes you work for
the good guys, but usually you don’t. It
seems like even though you’re constantly
interfering with human history, you don’t
even care about it.
I just hate when people, and also microbes,
are super self-involved. Like, don’t tell
me you gotta take a day off to go to your
mom’s birthday party, Stan. That’s not
imagining me complexly. I’ve got needs over
here.
Best wishes, John Green.
So continued defeat and the death of his troops
eventually convinced Napoleon to give up his
dreams of an American empire and cut his losses.
He recalled his surviving troops, of the 40,000
who left, only 8,000 made it back. And then,
he sold Thomas Jefferson Louisiana. And that
is how former slaves in Haiti gave America
all of this.
On January 1, 1804, Dessalines who had defeated
the French, declared the island of Saint-Domingue
independent and re-named it Haiti, which is
what the island had been called by the native
inhabitants before the arrival of Columbus.
The Haitian Declaration of Independence was
a rejection of France and, to a certain degree
of European racism and colonialism.
It also affirmed, to quote from the book Slave
Revolution in the Caribbean, “a broad definition
of the new country as a refuge for enslaved
peoples of all kinds.” So, why is this little
island so important that we would devote an
entire episode to it? First, Haiti was the
second free and independent nation state in
the Americas. It also had one of the most
successful slave revolts ever. Haiti became
the first modern nation to be governed by
people of African descent, and they also foiled
Napoleon’s attempts to build a big new world empire
Of course, Haiti’s history since its revolution
has been marred by tragedy, a legacy of the
loss of life that accompanied the revolution.
I mean, 150,000 people died in 1802 and 1803
alone. But the Haitian revolutions matter.
They matter because the Haitians, more than
any other people in the age of revolutions,
stood up for the idea that none should be
slaves, that the people who most need the
protection of a government should be afforded
that protection. Haiti stood up for the weak
when the rest of the world failed to.
The next time you read about Haiti’s
poverty, remember that.
Thanks for watching. I’ll see you next week.
Crash Course is produced and directed by Stan
Muller. Our script supervisor is Danica Johnson.
The show is ably interned by Meredith Danko.
And our graphics team is Thought Bubble. Oh,
right, I write it with my high school history
teacher Raoul Meyer. Actually, he does most
of the work, who are we kidding.
Last week’s phrase of the week was “fancy
footwear.” If you want to guess this week’s
phrase of the week or suggest future ones,
you can do so in comments, where you can also
ask questions that will be answered by our
team of historians.
Thanks for watching Crash Course, and as we
say in my home town, Don't Forget To Be Awesome.